I recently been experiencing a lot of,
like, good anxiety.
Like, good things happening,
and then it gives me that anxiety feeling like,
oh, my god, oh,
my god, oh, my god.
But it's for good reason.
But then I feel like my body
can't tell the difference between good anxiety or,
like, you know,
the bad anxiety.
And so then, you know,
usually after anxiety comes depression.
And so then,
even though it's been,
like, really,
really good things happening and I'm excited about shit,
I still have days that I'm, like,
waking up crying and, like,
having such a hard time with everything,
like, all my feelings,
because it's like my body thinks,
like, oh, well,
you're just anxious.
So now let's balance you out
and make you feel a little bit depressed.
And it's like,
it was good.
There's nothing to be sad about.
And that's a journey I'm exploring.
Thank you for listening.